we cannot continue simply to be
prisoners of this crisis we're preparing
now slowly cautiously to come out of
hibernation and I believe it's
absolutely vital for us to set out the
way ahead so that everyone can think and
plan for the future short medium and
long term because if the cryptic opioid
crisis has taught us one thing it's that
this country needs to be ready for what
may be coming and we need to be able to
move with levels of energy and speed
that we have not needed for generations
and I know that there are plenty of
things that people will say and we got
wrong and we owe that discussion and
that honesty to the tens of thousands
who have died before their time to the
families who have lost loved ones and of
course there must be time to learn the
lessons and we will but I also know that
some things went right and emphatically
right and I think of the speed and
efficiency with which we put up the
nightingales ten days for a hospital I
think of the drive and inventiveness of
the British companies who rose to the
ventilator challenge with three brand
new production lines called into being
within the space of eight weeks with a
new model a ventilator developed in
March and granted regulatory approval in
weeks a nine and a half thousand of them
now made I pay tribute to the pace which
Oxford University managed to perform the
trials for dexamethasone the world's
first demonstrably life-saving treatment
for the disease I mean all of the
problem crunching Fury with which HMRC
and the Treasury created the furlough
scheme and all the other means of
support world leading standards of
protection for jobs and incomes set up
in a matter of days they were brilliant
and determined individuals who
more than rose to the challenge of this
crisis there were thousands and
thousands who put their hearts and souls
into it and yet our debt is not just to
them it's not just even to the devotion
and the love of the NHS and the care
workers who saved so many lives
including my own
there was one big reason in the end that
we were able to avert a far worse
disaster and that was because the whole
of society came together to make a
sacrifice on behalf of those who might
be particularly vulnerable particularly
the elderly
we all knew when we went into lockdown
that there would be huge economic costs
and we could see what would happen and
yet we did it
the United Kingdom in a display of
solidarity not seen since the Second
World War and so today we must combine
that energy and drive with that
concentrated burst of collective
willpower that protected the NHS and
control the virus and saved literally
hundreds of thousands of lives and we
must work fast because we've already
seen the vertiginous drop in GDP and we
know that people are worried now about
their jobs and their businesses and were
waiting as if between the flash of
lightning and the Thunder Clap with our
hearts in our mouths for the full
economic reverberations to appear and so
we've must use this moment now
this interval to plan our response and
to fix of course the problems that were
most brutally illuminated in that Cove
aid lightning flash the problems in our
social care system the parts of
government that seemed to respond so
sluggishly so that sometimes it seemed
like that recurring bad dream
you're telling your feet to run and your
feet won't move yet we must also go
further and realize that if we are to
recover fully if we're to deal with the
coming economic aftershock then this
Kovach crisis is also the moment to
address the problems in our country that
we have failed to tackle for decades
because it's one of the most
extraordinary features of the UK in so
many ways the greatest place on earth
that we tolerate such yawning gaps
between the best and the rest we have
some of the best and most productive
companies in the world and yet we are
not as nationally productive as many of
our global competitors we have the
world's most brilliant medical minds the
world's best pharmaceutical companies
our doctors our treatments are the best
in the world
and yet we have so many millions who
have to wait for too long to see their
GP even before the new waiting lists
produced by the crisis we have umpteen
fantastic globally outstanding
universities and yet too many degree
courses are not now delivering value and
for a century we've failed to invest
enough in further education and give
young people the practical training and
further education they need we have a
capital city London what is we'll be in
so many ways the capital of the world
grows they too Andy
Theatre finance tech restaurants you
name it London leaves the world and yet
too many parts of our amazing country
but felt left behind neglected unloved
as though someone had taken a strategic
decision that their fate did not matter
as much as the metropolis so I want you
to know that this government not only
has a vision to change this country for
the better we have a mission to unite
and to level up and it's the mission on
which we're elected last year
and we have a plan and in advancing that
plan now I just serve notice that we
will not be responding to this crisis
with what people called austerity we're
not going to cheese pear our way out of
trouble because the world has moved on
since 2008 and we not only face a new
and in some ways far bigger challenge
and I can tell everybody businesses that
next week the Chancellor Ritchie sooner
will be setting out our immediate plan
to support the economy through the first
phase of the recovery but this moment
also gives us a much greater chance to
be radical and to do things differently
to build back better and to build that
Boulder and so we will be doubling down
on our strategy we will double down on
leveling up if you can make sense of
that
and when I say level up I don't mean I
don't mean attacking our great companies
or I don't mean impeding the success of
London far from it or launching some
punitive raid on the wealth creators I
don't believe in tearing people down any
more than I believe in tearing down
statues that are part of our heritage
they learn a statue of our greatest
wartime leader
I believe in building people up giving
everyone growing up in this country the
opportunity they need whoever you are
whatever your ethnicity
whatever your background and there are
certain things that are indispensable
for that opportunity Hospital you're
born in schools you go to the safety of
the streets where you grow up and this
government has not forgotten that we
were elected to build 40 new hospitals
and we will Matt Hancock you setting out
the list in the next few days and that
is just the
beginning we will continue and step up
the biggest-ever program of funding the
NHS and we won't wait to fix the
problems of social care for every
government has flunked for the last 30
years we will end the injustice that
some people have to sell their homes to
finance the cost of their care while
others don't and we're finalizing our
plans and we will build a cross-party
consensus we want to look after those
who have looked after us and at the same
time we will build the foundations now
for future prosperity to make this
country a Britain that is fully
independent and self-governing for the
first time in 45 years the most
attractive place to live to invest to
set up a company we're the most
motivated and highly skilled workforce
and so we're investing massively now in
education with over 14 billion pounds of
primary and secondary education between
now and 2020 3 and today with a new
10-year school building programme begin
beginning now with 1 billion pounds for
the first 50 schools and a vast 1.5
billion pound program for refurbishing
our
dilapidated Fe sector dilapidated in
many places not here of course because
it's time it's time that the system
recognized the talent and genius are
expressed as much by hand and by eye as
they are by a spreadsheet or an essay so
when I say unite and level up when I say
build up people and build up talent I
want to end the current injustice that
means a pupil from a London state school
is now 50% more likely to go to a top
university for the pupil from the West
Midlands and that is not only unjust it
is such a waste of human talent we will
unleash the potential of the entire
country